dude the new Star Wars trailer just rot
[Music]
deported what are you doing
you do realize that if we don't get this
up like now our subscribers are gonna be
really mad at us right
is this because mark hamill said not to
watch this trailers alright guys hope
you enjoyed that intro we got Angela in
the movie source channel here with us
today two things before we go into the
reaction right now first things first
we've been using the Stardust app a lot
so make sure to follow us there at the
real rejects download it and follow us
it allows us to do 30-second reactions
to any trailers films or TV shows and
secondly gareth hood I remembered your
son Yousef deserves a shout out for the
last Jedi you claim this a long time ago
let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
that's like shots oh cool yeah he's
always been
but I was awake
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
I see this roster easily once before
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
why
[Music]
I need someone to show me my place in
all this
[Music]
[Applause]
get your tickets now we already got our
ticket we knew we'd have them we've seen
it already we know what happens and if
you want to get our instant thoughts on
the movie in 30 seconds make sure to
download that start us at people it's
and feedback for you right away within
30 seconds all go reject follow the real
rejects download it first reactions any
movie TV show train that's right
probably put up a reaction to this
trailer alright well this video is done
take care of you yeah oh that was
mesmerizing talk about going down a much
darker path you know what I'm not
concerned about you know like oh for zoo
aliens is just new hope and I have my
disagreements whatever this looks like
an entirely different thing there's some
reminiscent stuff of Empire Strikes Back
in terms of Luke training rags yeah yes
you get of Yoda and Luke fives accept
the mentorship relationship it's all
really different because Luke it seems
like I don't know if I really want to do
this very reluctant the whole time I
kind of spooked by red yeah I've heard
theories about like how he's hiding from
Snoke and you get a little brief image
of Snoke not in hologram format which
was really creepy to see and there's
just so much teases going on
you know like in that scene kylo Ren
gonna kill Leia is that what's going on
also that will that ending moment where
Ray's reaching out her hand to kylo they
they reach out of their hands to each
other looking for guidance which side is
Reagan a fall under and I like the
marketing tease of it of going
is she gonna turn bad in the end I
thought like the whole goal was to try
to get kylo to possibly turn good in the
end so a lot of theories I've never
liked both of those theoretically work
here cuz I don't know quite where kylo
that and what his motivation is either
oh I know that is we're gonna see him
wreck some things again even that scene
with leia and evaan at the scene the end
like the looks on his face don't suggest
like this guy's purely evil yeah there's
a lot of intrigue in this trailer and I
like that and on a technical standpoint
this looks like it'll be the best shot
Star Wars film oh yeah absolutely say
this looks like the best shots and some
lightsaber fights actual Star Wars
battle sequences one just the way some
of the shots are framed in the lighting
like the the stark like reds and
things like that it seems like they're
really going all out with the look of
the movie all right you know the format
Andrew we get our thoughts that way here
you go I think the biggest thing I got
from all of this was spiritual depth I
think you kind of had said my thoughts
this the cinematography in this film the
way the camera is moving up through octo
and through crate the mineral planet
where we see the red salt come from and
again those new gorilla walkers
he looks so sick and you know why they
call them gorilla walkers because they
can climb on trees and you throw bananas
at them but you know they do look really
drunk barrels on your yes they do
I love how thick the the legs look I
mean there's just so many different
interesting elements I think the biggest
thing also that I thought I thought was
like incredibly like in terms of the
human death was that that conflicting
moment of Pyla like is he gonna shoot
there or is it a misdirect like it's
just it just adds so much more because
there's obviously gonna be so many
incredible action sequences when I hit
the dramatic side cuz that's what makes
it all we're so special when you get the
the human depth and the dramatic tension
from it let's go what I felt in those
moments it really feels like everything
they're setting they set up from the
force awakens they're gonna really gonna
start getting a lot of answers and a lot
more information actually seen Snoke
attacking Rey at that one moment even
just having Finn and an attendant as
finally heard those complaints yeah yeah
they're fighting each other in that
sequence you're like yes they built up
them fighting in the force awakens where
there's specific dynamics and you're
getting that here so let's watch one
more time
when I found you
[Music]
Stephanie and beyond that
[Music]
octo
me it's always been
and I was awake really give your CMS
[Music]
I've seen this roster easily before
[Music]
I love that like yes it overcomes trauma
at me
[Music]
even stronger
[Music]
it's so great because he kills Han in
the first one - it goes bottom out
that's great I don't know that good oh
yeah simpler phone scene I'm so excited
for
[Music]
he gets captured
I need someone to show me my place and
all this I'm so excited for this is this
looks fantastic
it seems like too like something has
gone really wrong with Luke and Rey in
terms of their training like this what
she's saying it looks like the kylo Ren
like you know maybe it seems like she
isn't that he isn't like exactly the
trainer the hero she thought he was well
I mean I'm taking a couple ways I mean
one way that seems like the obvious
thought to have is he trained kylo and
then that's what he's worried about is
like oh that strength is what kylo had
is when you're talking about spiritual
death earlier like I really noted the
first part of this trailer is Snoke is
talking to kylo and he's talking about I
felt something within and there's
something special and then it goes to
Rey who's saying I feel something within
and I need to understand what it is and
it seems like this movie is really gonna
be about them figuring out their
identities and I feel like that's why
the trailer ends on that scene with kylo
and Ray because it's about them figuring
out what is really in them and what
they're both meant to be
that's what I find incredibly intriguing
I feel like it'll be focused really on
on the light and the dark oh this looks
fantastic yeah maybe in between if
they're gonna go into the gray Jedi
story yeah they're really quick just for
anybody the gray Jedi basically what
that is when you tiptoe between the line
between the light and the dark side but
you don't fully surrender yourself to
the dark side and I feel like in that
scene where you do see Snoke I mean the
theory I heard is that snow sucks the
life force out of people and the theory
I heard was of the Knights of Ren and I
kind of just on reserve for when Snoke
needs life force and so I'm hope I'm
thinking that's probably what's going on
in that scene it's great because you
don't have any definitive answers in
here just a lot of great other questions
to ponder and I feel like they're
catering to the Star Wars fans I'd love
to theorize I'm so excited for this and
hey before I wrap up this video
Yussef my friend Gareth ability your
daddy on patreon asked us a long time
ago he said can you please just make
sure the next Star Wars trailer that
comes out that you get my son use of a
shadow and yousuf we love your dad and
we'd love you you are a fantastic little
boy and I hope your dad takes you to see
this and isn't some selfish father who
held out on Netflix for you for the past
few years I heard he finally got you a
Netflix account it's about time he has
one do not have him make you wait to go
watch this when it comes out
in December while you guys are living in
the Middle East do you understand
yourself subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell - on
Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram this
is andrew from the movie source channel
make sure to follow him there and like
we said earlier follow us on the
stardust app download and follow us at
the Rio rejects and posting quite a lot
on there a lot of your favorite
youtubers use it as well so we're part
of the community there we really want
really want people to know that yeah
follow us first much love reject nation
much love